let's talk a little bit about the covid
pandemic we may be approaching what what
might be the first so what wave and i'm
not the person who came up with that
there's a good atlantic article that
uses that term we had the original wave
we had delta we had omicron
and we may be getting to the first so
what wave where
most people may just not do anything
differently we just don't know
but
pandemic fatigue aside
it's starting to look like something may
be happening so a few headlines
philadelphia is restoring indoor mask
mandates as cases rise we've gotten away
from almost any mask mandates yes
transportation federally although that
may go away april 18th
although it may not now that the numbers
are starting to rise in some places
again
um
medical facilities in in i think most
states i don't i don't even remember if
that's federal in most places you go to
the doctor you're still supposed to wear
a mask at least in the northeast
um but we are starting to see some
things happen again philadelphia will
restore its indoor mask mandate the
associated press reporting confirmed
coveted cases up more than 50 percent in
10 days that's a predetermined threshold
where the city says masks go back on
indoors
this is being driven by the ba2
sub-variant of omicron amic the original
omicron was ba1
ba2 is this sub-variant of omicron
u.s state department orders all
non-emergency government staff in
shanghai china to leave as covid surges
um
[Music]
however the chinese foreign ministry is
not pleased with this on saturday
chinese foreign ministry spokesperson
xiao li jian
said the us characterization of china's
coveted policy was a groundless
accusation and that the chinese side has
assisted foreign diplomats and consular
staff on covid related
issues
this is in response to the u.s state
department warning about the arbitrary
enforcement of local laws
universities reinstating mask mandates
amid covid surge
the american university announced monday
it's putting a mask mandate back on in
d.c columbia georgetown johns hopkins
rice universities are also doing this
the reason the highly transmissible ba2
sub variant
an average of more than 31 000 new covet
cases across the country
covet could be surging in the u.s and we
might not even know about it this is
also an important issue and i know a lot
of people are sick of hearing about this
we know
that there is less testing going on
we also know that a lot of the home
testing is not being reported to
authorities so a lot of people this
started to be an issue during the the
first omicron wave in december
it's an even bigger issue now where
increasingly a lot of people are testing
at home
testing positive
and then they throw the test out and
they go i'm positive and that's it that
doesn't show up in the numbers anywhere
uh not not to you know
i'm not i have no reason to think sam
cedar is doing this but we sadly learned
yesterday that our friend sam cedar from
the majority report has tested positive
he's had a bunch of different negative
tests didn't feel well now he's positive
i don't know what type of a test that
was but the point i'm making is without
accusing sam of anything if sam's
eventual positive test was a home test
that's not automatically counted
anywhere unless sam reports it and
because of the decrease decreased not
only in people seeking tests but also
the decrease in some of these municipal
and federal testing sites
we we just know we're almost certainly
not capturing all of the cases that are
going on so what's going to happen i
don't know
i am
convinced that the threshold
for people going back into a cautious
state is much higher much much higher
than it was before uh and what i mean by
that is a slight increase in cases and
deaths at this point for social reasons
is not going to kind of drive us back
in terms of our precautions i think
people are much more comfortable
accepting a certain level of risk i'm
not immune to that i went to las vegas
last week
i i there were there was not a mask in
sight i was around thousands of people
and um
thankfully i didn't i didn't get sick
and uh you know when i got back i i
didn't see people for four days until i
really knew i was in the clear but would
i have done that at a previous time you
know probably not at the same time the
numbers look a lot better so we're going
to have to see
what happens i think you will absolutely
see
a much more stark difference between
states
as in all likelihood cases continue to
rise and eventually hospitalizations do
as well
let me know your perspective on this let
me know what you're doing let me know
what you're seeing in your state you can
find me on twitter at deepakman and one
week from today at 6 pm eastern we'll
have the next david pakman show town
hall i hope you'll join everybody gets
to ask questions and it will be
streaming live on the pacman live
youtube channel
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blink is for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below